Let us examine how to interpret
the model we developed.
One of the things
we should look after
is that there might be what
is called multicollinearity.
Multicollinearity occurs
when the various independent
variables are
correlated, and this
might confuse the coefficients--
the betas-- in the model.
So tests to address that involve
checking the correlations
of independent variables.
If they are
excessively high, this
would mean that there
might be multicollinearity,
and you have to potentially
revisit the model,
as well as whether the signs
of the coefficients make sense.
Is the coefficient beta
positive or negative?
If it agrees with intuition,
then multicollinearity
has not been a problem,
but if intuition suggests
a different sign, this might
be a sign of multicollinearity.
The next important
element is significance.
So how do we
interpret the results,
and how do we understand whether
we have a good model or not?
For that purpose,
let's take a look
at what is called Area Under
the Curve, or AUC for short.
So the Area Under the Curve
shows an absolute measure
of quality of prediction-- in
this particular case, 77.5%,
which means that, given that
the perfect score is 100%,
so this is like a B,
whereas, as we'll see later,
a 50% score, which
is pure guessing,
is a 50% rate of success.
So the area under the curve
gives an absolute measure
of quality, and it's less
affected by various benchmarks.
So it illustrates how
accurate the model
is on a more absolute sense.
So what is a good AUC?
The area on the right
shows the maximum possible
of a perfect prediction,
whereas the area on this
curve now-- it is 0.5,
and it's pure guessing.
Other outcome measures that
are important for us to discuss
is the so-called
confusion matrix.
So the matrix here is formulas
for the various terms we use.
The actual class is 0--
means, in our example,
good quality of care,
and actual class = 1
means poor quality of care,
whereas the predicted class =
0 means that will
predict good quality,
and the predicted class = 1 mean
that we predict poor quality.
So we define true
negatives, short by TN.
False positives, short by FP.
False negatives, FN, and
true positives by TP.
So if N is the number
of observations,
the overall accuracy
is basically
the number of true negatives
and true positives divided by N.
It's basically the terms
in the diagonal of this two
by two matrix divided by
the total observations.
The overall error rate is
the terms off-diagonal--
the false positives, plus
the false negatives, divided
by the total number
of observations.
That's the overall
measure of an error rate.
An important component is
the so-called sensitivity,
and sensitivity is TP, the
true positives, whenever
we predict poor
quality, and indeed it
is poor quality, divided by TP,
these true positives, plus FN,
which is the total number
of cases of poor quality.
So this is the total
number of times
that we predict poor
quality, and it is, indeed,
poor quality, versus the
total number of times
the actual quality
is, in fact, poor.
False negative rate is FN,
the number of false negatives,
divided by the number
of true positives,
plus the number of
false negatives.
And specificity is
TN, true negatives,
the number of times we
predict the quality is good,
and, in fact, the
quality is good,
divided by this number,
TN, plus false positives.
So specificity is
the number of times
we predict the quality is
good, and it is indeed good,
versus the total times
we have good quality,
and the false
positive error rate is
1 minus the specificity.
So in this particular example
that we have discussed,
quality of care, just
like in linear regression,
we want to make
predictions on a test set
to compute
out-of-sample metrics.
We develop the logistic
regression model using data,
but would like to make
predictions out-of-sample.
So in our test, we
utilized 32 cases,
and the R command that
makes the statements
about the quality of a
prediction out-of-sample
is illustrated
here in the slide.
So in that way, we
make predictions
about probabilities,
of course, simply
because logistic regression
makes predictions
about probabilities, and
then we transform them
to a binary outcome--
the quality is good,
or the quality is poor--
using a threshold.
In this particular example, we
used a threshold value of 0.3,
and in doing so, we obtain the
following confusion matrix.
So there were, as I
mentioned, there are 32 cases,
out of which 24 of them
are actually good care,
and eight of them are
actually poor care.
We observe that the overall
accuracy of the model
is 19 plus 6, is 25, over 32.
The false positive rate is,
in this case, 5 over 24,
19 plus 5, whereas the true
positive rate is 6 out of 8-- 6
plus 2.
Notice, if you compare this
model with making always--
let's say one
alternative is to say
we predict good
care all the time.
In that situation,
we will be correct 19
plus 5, 24 times, versus
25 times, in our case.
But notice that predicting
always good care
does not capture the dynamics
of what is happening,
versus the logistic
regression model that
is far more intelligent in
capturing these effects.